un policier tué par des gangsters au
cours d'un hold up à paris il ya
plusieurs blessés de part et d'autre
vous avez dit cohabitation l'ancien
président giscard d'estaing répond
clairement oui
il en serait aujourd'hui dans la
campagne électorale voilà seulement
perçant sous demi surveillance pas
d'administrateur provisoire pour le
programmer un mandataire chargé de
veiller au sein du couple début des
masters aux etats-unis le gratin du
tennis se retrouvent à new york et en
direct ce soir sur antenne 2 madame
monsieur bonsoir c'est le douzième
policier ou gendarme a battu depuis un
an par des gangsters cela s'est passé
cet après midi à paris un hold up qui a
mal tourné dans une banque du 16e
arrondissement ou cours de la fusillade
un policier de la brigade de recherche
et d'intervention la berri a été tué il
y a plusieurs blessés patrice pollet
s'est tout de suite rendu sur place dans
cette voiture du samu l'un des
malfaiteurs grièvement blessé après le
hold up à la succursale du crédit du
nord
il est 16h30 lorsque les gangsters sorte
de la banque
mais la police les a tant les gangsters
sont en effet filets depuis le début de
la journée
les malfaiteurs se rendent compte qu'ils
sont tombés dans une souricière
immédiatement ils ouvrent le feu de part
et d'autre on se tire dessus presque à
bout portant
on allait rentrer chez moi de ce que
j'ai vu très vivace j'ai vu les coups de
feu qui sont posées qu'ils sont
lieux et ses produits la chose suivante
c'est que j'ai vu un policier qui était
gravement atteints et puis un défenseur
qui était mort il y en avait un il y
avait seulement ils avaient des
perruques une perruque par terre et puis
comment vit le rêve des blousons c'est
tout les malfaiteurs n'en reste pas là
pour protéger leur fuite ils prennent en
otage un policier qu'ils relâcheront
quelques instants plus tard le patron de
la brb le commissaire mertz est
légèrement blessé suite à cette affaire
en fin de soirée deux suspectes ont été
interpellées et relâchées
quant aux autres gangsters ils sont peu
toujours en fuite
moins dramatique le casse d'une agence
de la société générale encore à paris 21
coffre pillée par des postiches toujours
le même scénario
une demi-douzaine de gangsters s'empare
des employés à l'ouverture de la banque
et prennent tout leur temps pour vider
les coffres
pourtant l'actualité de ce mardi est
bien c'est aussi le spectacle politique
à gauche comme à droite en ce début de
campagne électorale aujourd'hui l'acteur
essentiel en était l'ancien président
giscard d'estaing qui occupaient la
scène à deux jours de la publication de
la plate forme de l'opposition l'ancien
chef de l'état qui marque une nouvelle
fois la différence avec raymond barre en
insistant sur la nécessité de la
cohabitation
c'était tout à l'heure à l'assemblée
nationale est il possible d'obliger à
partir contre sa volonté
un président élu pour sept ans certains
vous répondent oui je vous dis non
pour toi c'est parce que je veux que la
france et la politique d'un grand pays
un grand pays respectent les règles et
fait face aux réalités même difficile
monsieur giscard d'estaing ensuite
préciser sa position sur ce que
devraient être les pouvoirs respectifs
du premier ministre et du président de
la république dans le cadre de la
cohabitation des pouvoirs qui seront
dans cette hypothèse précis et limités
monsieur giscard d'estaing le président
de la république nomme le premier
ministre
mais il n'a pas le pouvoir de le
renvoyer
et je le chai
car c'est un sujet dont j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'entretenir avec les
premiers ministres que j'avais nommé le
premier ministre de la cohabitation sera
indéboulonnable deuxième chose qu'il
faut savoir c'est que c'est le premier
ministre qui choisit les ministres et
sur des sujets pourtant
traditionnellement attribué au président
comme le référendum et la révision de la
constitution le président de la
république ne peut agir que sur
proposition du gouvernement pratiquement
ça signifie quoi
ça signifie que le président de la
république n'a aucun moyen de s'opposer
à la mise en place d'une nouvelle
politique lorsqu'elle est voulue par le
gouvernement et par la majorité
parlementaire
monsieur giscard d'estaing à continue
donc de vouloir de souhaiter la
cohabitation il a donc redit tout à
l'heure et il continue donc de plaider
en même temps pour une sorte
d'alternance 12 paul amar c'est bien
cela absolument il reste fidèle à lui
même l'auteur du livre deux français sur
trois continuent de militer pour la
réconciliation nationale
valéry giscard d'estaing qui a cité à
plusieurs reprises des hommes du 19e
siècle s'inspire en fait de philosophes
du xviiie
comme jean jacques rousseau l'ancien
président se veut optimiste
il croit à la bonne volonté des hommes
donc à la coexistence pacifique
mais comme il ne veut pas verser dans
l'utopie il fixe tout de même la règle
du jeu
sa règle du jeu elle passe par une
lecture très personnelle de la
constitution effet du premier ministre
le véritable chef au sens littéral du
terme du gouvernement
bien sûr le président pourrait rester
sous l'opposition gagne en mars 86 mais
un président sans pouvoirs il
conserverait sa couronne mais il devrait
rendre son sceptre théoriquement la
démonstration de valéry giscard
d'estaing peut convaincre mais elle ne
tient pas compte du caractère des hommes
or on imagine mal françois mitterrand
abdiqué et se muer en présidant
chrysanthèmes en outre ce scénario
proposé par son prédécesseur est destiné
à éviter la guerre civile froide peut
transformer à terme la nature des
relations entre le président de la
république et le premier ministre
imaginons qu après demain les majorités
pas
le mans terre et présidentielles
coïncide à nouveau le chef du
gouvernement
s'il devait appliquer les
recommandations de valéry giscard
d'estaing pourrait avoir la tentation de
revendiquer tous les pouvoirs et de
défier ainsi le chef de l'état le cas ne
s'est jamais produit depuis
cinquante-huit même jacques chaban
delmas
plébiscité pourtant par la majorité
avaient préféré s'effacer en 72 lé futur
premier ministre
auront-ils la même attitude demain pas
sûr si le pouvoir devait être transféré
de l'elysée à matignon
et c'est tout l'esprit de la cinquième
qui serait ainsi modifier la politique
c'est aussi le coup du rideau en
nouvelle calédonie le ministre de
l'intérieur pierre joxe effectue
actuellement une visite de quatre jours
sur le territoire il était aujourd'hui à
nouméa où les anti indépendantistes
majoritaire dans cette région avait
décrété une opération ville morte
boutiques fermées et rideaux baissés rue
desserte c'est l'accueil qu'ils ont
réservé monsieur jacques sylla quand
même pu rencontrer trois présidents des
conseils de région puisque les
responsables indépendantistes avaient
répondu à son invitation
le ministre de l'intérieur doit
poursuivre demain sa visite dans
d'autres régions du territoire et là
c'est monsieur tjibaou qui arrive donc
pour rencontrer monsieur joxe robert
hersant sous demi surveillance après le
rachat du progrès de lyon le tribunal de
commerce qui avait été saisi au
lendemain de cette opération a rendu ce
matin son ordonnance le président avait
le choix entre deux solutions nommé un
administrateur provisoire ou ne pas le
nommer eh bien il en a choisi une
troisième en désignant un mandataire
judiciaire ce qui est très différent et
c'est ce que vous allez nous expliquer
paul lefèvre maintenant le président
jacques bon en effet nommer l'un de ses
prédécesseurs à la présidence du
tribunal de commerce de paris ne se
veulent pas clos pour cette tâche
délicate de mandataire judiciaire en
somme le tribunal de commerce de paris a
tenu le raisonnement suivant
premièrement pour l'instant il n'y a pas
d'autre repreneur déclaré que robert
hersant
deuxièmement robert hersant à des
capitaux un éventuel administrateur
judiciaire n'aurait peut-être pas trouvé
pour faire vivre le progrès c'est
important troisièmement monsieur pas
clos qui n'est pas un homme à se laisser
berner va donc être une sorte de tuteur
entre guillemets pour robert hersant je
ne sais pas si la formule à lui faire
plaisir
de façon à ce que monsieur r sanger le
progrès mais ne prennent aucune décision
irréversible avant que l'on décide au
civil et au pénal
si l'achat du progrès de lyon par robert
hersant est valable non question étudiée
par le tribunal de commerce à partir du
27 janvier prochain question posée
également au juge d'instruction claude
grelier qui au pénal pour être inculpé
robert hersant de violation de la loi de
84 sur la presse certains juristes
en effet alors que l'immunité
parlementaire du député européen ne peut
pas être invoquée en cas de flagrant
délit
bon reste il est vrai qu'en l'absence
d'autres candidats repreneurs ou
d'autres solutions dead au progrès de
lyon
robert hersant garde même sous
surveillance son fauteuil de pdg du
progrès et que pour l'instant
indéniablement le temps travaille pour
lui l'amiral lacoste l'ancien patron de
la dgse était au centre de la terre
greenpeace puisqu'il était au sommet le
patron des agents secrets français
impliqué dans la sphère c'est un homme
réservé qui est constamment resté
silencieux
quelques fûts ces attaques portées
contre lui il n'a jamais voulu répondre
ou apporter des éléments qui permettent
de corroborer une thèse ou une autre il
sort aujourd'hui de son silence non pas
pour apporter des révélations
fracassantes mais pour expliquer les
raisons de son mutisme
il s'en est entretenu tout à l'heure
avec hervé brusini qui avait suivi pour
nous une enquête autour de greenpeace et
qui lui a présenté quelques unes des
images qui avaient marqué cette histoire
ce bateau ou le reconnaissait amiral
toi tu réellement on a parlé d'une
troisième équipe à sabotage du sabotage
c'est vrai j'ai l'intention de faire
aucun commentaire sur une affaire pour
laquelle j'avais décidé en conformité
avec mon sens de la responsabilité en
tant que chef des services secrets donc
de ne faire aucun commentaire
après tout ceux qui ont été faits dans
les différents médias et par différentes
bush
et cette femme là quelqu'un que je n'ai
pas besoin de voir pour y penser
constamment
j'ai le plus grand respect pour les gens
qui étaient sous mes ordres et qui se
sont trouvés victime d'un malheureux
accident et dans toute la mesure de mes
possibilités
je ferai en sorte de participer à leur
libération aussi c'est possible pour moi
vous dites un accident amiral est à
entendre que l'opération a mal tourné
tout simplement non jeudi un accident
sans plus ce sont des agents de la dgse
qui ont coulé ce bateau il dans les
pages y surfe sur ordre de qui et mira
lacoste
c'est une question à laquelle j'ai dit
que je ne répondrai pas ce matin je ne
peux pas y répondre plus ce soir vous
n'avez pas non plus répondu aux
autorités politiques lorsqu'elle vous
ont demandé comment tout cela c'était
passé pourquoi ce silence
ils n'ont refus a été apportée sur un
seul point qui a consisté à ne pas
donner le nom de 2,2 mais à blanc si je
les fais c'est parce que en conscience
et en fonction de ma conception d'un
déontologie des services secrets j'ai
estimé que je n'avais pas le droit de
mettre en danger des hommes qui ont
accepté de servir sous mes ordres et qui
peuvent légitimement s'attendre à ce que
je prenne mes responsabilités vis-à-vis
de cette sorte de pacte entre vous et
vos hommes est ce que ça n'aboutit pas à
la constitution d'un état dans l'état
absolument pas c'est une question de
loyauté
c'est une question qu'il se rapproche
de la façon de faire de la plupart des
hauts fonctionnaires et des militaires
en ce sens que comme dans toute
profession dans tout métier il ya un
certain nombre de règles qui s'imposent
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse me de taxer
de déloyauté vis-à-vis de qui que ce
soit pierre enseignement c'est un point
important dans dans la défense
maintenant oui et c'est bien pour ça que
j'ai accepté de venir aujourd'hui en
pesant les avantages et les
inconvénients de notre présence c'est
simplement pour exprimer ma conviction à
l'occasion du la sortie d'une nouvelle
édition de mon livre que les affaires de
défense et de stratégie
ce n'est pas seulement la mise en oeuvre
des appareils militaires des armées des
marines des aviations mais c'est aussi
pour une très large part la connaissance
du monde et la connaissance des
adversaires potentiels
et dans cette optique le renseignement a
une importance tout à fait capital qui
dans notre pays n'a peut-être pas
toujours été suffisamment perçue oui
l'amiral lacoste qui a maintenant
quelques loisirs et qui vient du publier
ce livre dans lequel il n'évoque pas
l'affairé greenpeace mais il détaille la
stratégie navale à travers le monde
c'est un vrai livre de marins et est
édité chez jean claude lattès
les patrons à la recherche d'un nouveau
salaire minimum le cnpf voudraient
remplacer le smic négocié par les
partenaires sociaux au profit d'un
nouveau smic fixé cette fois par l'état
de la sorte il ne serait pas seulement
indexé sur la hausse des prix mais aussi
sur d'autres critères actuellement le
smic est de 26 francs 04 douleur ce qui
fait un peu plus de 4400 francs par mois
il y aura t il un compromis entre la
majorité gouvernementale et l'opposition
sénatoriale sur la flexibilité
on verra bien c'est en tout cas ce qu'a
de mon maire a laissé entendre ce matin
à l'issue d'une rencontre avec le
président du sénat monsieur power et
avec jean pierre fourcade qui est le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales vous savez que le parlement est
actuellement réuni en session
extraordinaire pour discuter justement
de ce projet de loi sur l'aménagement du
temps de travail à l'étranger parmi les
exigences des ravisseurs des quatre
otages français du liban certaines
porterait sur des personnes plus
précisément sur la libération de
certaines personnes détenus en france
et l'on pense bien sûr au commando qui
avait tenté d'assassiner l'ancien
ministre iranien chapour bakhtiar en
tout cas c'est la première fois qu'un
ministre reconnaît qu'il y à bien de
telles exigences et les ravisseurs c'est
donc ce qu'a dit ce matin monsieur
roland dur on se bat est aujourd'hui
encore hayden au yémen du sud entre
troupes gouvernementales et rebelles ce
sont les suites d'un coup d'état au
cours duquel le président sud- yéménite
mohamed a été blessée par l'un de ses
rivaux dans cette affaire c'est la
nature des liens entre moscou et ce pays
qui paraît être en cause
il faut savoir que l'ours occupe à aden
une place privilégiée sur le plan
stratégique à l'entrée de la mer rouge
et c'est peut-être le rapprochement de
l'équipe dirigeante actuelle avec le
north yémen et l'arabie saoudite qui est
à l'origine des événements de ces
derniers des pépins pour ariane après un
premier report la semaine passée la
fusée européenne devait décoller jeudi
prochain eh bien le compte à rebours a
été annulée et le tir repoussé à la fin
à la fin février ou même au début du
mois de mars c'est un nouveau coup dur
pour ariane 5 mois cinq mois a pas un
échec bien douloureux
patrick esther 14h30 une porte qui
claque cet après-midi un cours ou les
malheurs d'ariane recommence
l'évidence s'impose aux techniciens qui
effectué les dernières répétitions
ce réservoir en forme d'anneau entourant
le moteur du deuxième étage fui comme
une vulgaire tuyauterie de baignoire ce
réservoir contient l'eau du circuit de
refroidissement
sale coup pour ce 16ème exemplaire de la
fusée européenne
le tir est reportée jusqu'au début du
mois de mars il est probable qu il va
être nécessaire de démonter le deuxième
étage peut-être même de le sortir de la
tour de lancement
ariane après l'échec du 13 septembre
sera donc 5 mois s'envoler reste
maintenant à savoir si ariane 17 qui
attention un second pas de lancement
sera tirée elle comme prévu le 26
février
mais de toute manière ce nouveau retard
fait mauvais effet dans la compétition
commerciale qui opposa rien à la navette
américaine
même s'il est trop tôt pour dire quelle
sera la réaction des clients
il est difficile de ne pas rire jaune en
pensant aux plaisanteries récentes liées
aux faux départ de la navette
on nous a mal renseigné on s'est trompés
d'adressé une excuse bien banal pour un
crime bien nous dieu hier soir trois
hommes masqués se sont introduits dans
la villa d'un célèbre restaurateur belge
qui vit dans le sud de la france ils
l'ont froidement abattus avant de
charger de soi disant microfilms qui
bien sûr ne s'y trouvait pas ils sont
repartis bredouille laissant à mort
derrière eux le reportage sur place de
thierry calmette à la villa le figuier
tout était calme et hier soir mais trois
hommes masqués venait de pénétrer dans
le jardin
madame henrion revenait du garage à
l'extérieur les gangs violents surprise
et faire entrer de force dans le salon
raymond en rayon gisait par terre
mortellement blessé par un coup de feu
les trois individus ont alors attachez
madame orient au corps de son époux
après avoir raflé quelques bijoux
ils ont demandé la clé du coffre puis
des microfilms sans résultat il aurait
alors prétendu s'être trompé d'adressé
les agresseurs se sont enfuis dans la
voiture du couple de retraités la
berline a été retrouvé à quelques
centaines de mètres de la ville l'a pas
d'empreinte les gangsters portait des
gants
voici madame henrion elle ne comprend
pas ils vivent t'avances depuis plus de
quinze ans le couple de retraités belges
possèdent un restaurant très coté en
belgique une existence sans histoire
rien à voir avec l'espionnage je connais
mes chiens en rayon depuis 40 ans je
sois je le souhaitais dentiste à sedan
vous savez cette à côté de son pays
n'est ce pas puisque ces dix étaient à
côté de la frontière pas gelé soigné
pendant des années je connais
parfaitement à l'homme la famille même
je peux vous dire c'est un homme
absolument intel qui n'a absolument rien
c'était disons le père tranquille c'est
vous qui avait ouvert le coffre
y avez vous trouvé oui c'est moi qui ai
ouvert ce matin en présence de madame
aurions évidemment on a trouvé quelques
billets à signifiant un carnet de chèque
postal mais absolument rien quelques
bijoux de fantaisie mais absolument
pas du tout d'anormal le retraité a
vraisemblablement été tuée à bout
touchant avec une arme de chasse au
canon scié ce qui écarterait
l'intervention d'agents secrets
cherchant d'hypothétiques microfilms ce
soir les policiers de cagnes de vence
penche plutôt pour l'hypothèse d'un
cambriolage manqué les cambrioleurs se
seraient affolés et aurait tiré
prétextant une affaire d'espionnage pour
brouiller les pistes pour l'instant
l'enquète demeure strictement policière
le sport maintenant avec un tableau de
maître à new york puisque c'est ce soir
que débute les fameux master le tournoi
des champions qui devrait permettre de
sacrés définitivement le meilleur joueur
de l'année 85 même simon est maintenant
en 1986 les joueurs qui sont difficiles
à départager auquel nous sommes amusés à
donner des notes en fonction de leurs
résultats de l'année voici le tableau
d'honneur du tennis mondial avec les six
meilleurs joueurs mais aussi avec les
deux français qui se produisent à new
york une copie notée par lionel
chamoulaud à lui la raquette d'or et de
diamants ivan lendl et enfin numéro un
la surface de new york lui est favorable
il est le favori dix tournois gagnés en
85 lui valent 20 sur 20
le boom de l'année boris becker un bon
jour de juillet il devient numéro 5
mondial c'est le plus jeune vainqueur de
wimbledon depuis c'est l'état de grâce
19 pour becker à 18 ans john mcenroe la
grimace
il gagne huit tournois mais aucun du
grand chelem la tête ailleurs peut-être
année médiocre puisqu'il n'est que
numéro 2 18 sur 20 l'homme de fin de
saison stefan edberg
vainqueur surprise de l'open d'australie
plus personne ne lui fait peur 18 aussi
pour le numéro 5 mondial
mats wilander toujours à désormais
numéro trois le vainqueur de roland
garros cherche un grand titre sur
surface synthétique une bonne année avec
trois victoires 17 sur 20 yannick noah
le grand retour avec trois titres et une
place de numéro 7
quelques soucis physiques mais la joie
de jouer et revenus 17 sur 20
le vieux lion rugit moins fort qu'au
nord n'a pas remporté un seul tournoi
cette année
rarissime pour le recordman des
victoires place et connor semé pas
gagnant 16 sur 20 henri leconte vous
saluent bien
deux titres de remarquables performances
dans les tournois du grand chelem
une motivation nouvelle dommage qu'en
vie et perdu huit fois au premier tour
cette année 15 sur 20 les 16 meilleurs
joueurs du monde sont à new york pour
élire le plus fort d'entre eux le maître
du tennis
85 premier match ce soir en direct sur
antenne 2 aux environs de 23 heures 45
après le dernier journal et puis
maintenant le paris dakar nous sommes à
mi parcours après le nettoyage par le
vide de la première semaine on serre les
rangs paris-dakar spécial antenne 2
voici le reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux jean-louis calmejane et patrick
chêne
puisqu'il était écrit que les problèmes
de navigation serait à l'ordre du jour
il était de bon ton très tôt ce matin de
réviser son cap et sa boussole ceci en
prenant sagement place dans la file
d'attenté du bac installé sur le niger
pour rejoindre un peu plus loin le mali
au départ de la première spéciale c'est
annie rolly qui résumait le sentiment
général guéï soit ça va être un vrai jeu
jeu de piste sur un terrain nouveau
oublié le désert du ténéré
ici la végétation existe elle est varié
et trompeuses
assez en tout cas pour s'y perdre et
tous s'y perdront deux tactiques alors
bien distinctes celle des motos tout de
suite attiré les unes vers les autres
pour rouler en peloton celle des
voitures maintenant c'est plutôt chacun
pour soi pour un surprenant ballet on ne
roule pas ensemble chacun sa route
chacun sa chance
autre tactique la bonne celle de rené
metge
est ce que c'est vous qu'on a vu leur
demande et la route des toits règle
exact
il allait à la ville lui a demandé sa
confirmer ce qu'ils nous disaient donc
on est parti là et il était à côté d'une
grande piste si tu veux dire une piste à
chameau 1
c'est presque comme une piste de
bagnoles mais y'a pas et rate de bagnols
si tu veux en avant lui en est tombé au
village si les porsche sont la course en
tête à seront battus tout de même battu
par une mitsubishi
curieusement pas par celle de zaniroli
engagé dans une mauvaise piste mais par
celle de caux and cowan suivi jusqu'au
bout par son coéquipier hubert rigal
cowan remporte l'étape mais mais je ne
perds pas grand chose dans la sphère
vainqueur du jour pareil
même situation maintenant chez les
motards cyril neveu les honda ne gagne
pas aujourd'hui mais elle ne perdre
qu'une grosse poignée de secondes au
profit des yamaha auteur d'un beau
doublé fine dano olivier
il n'y avait absolument aucun indice
pour pouvoir naviguer je pense que la
seule la seule solution c'était la
boussole et en faisant comme ça on s'est
retrouvé sur sur un cap à peu près
correct et on a trouvé la femme la
flamme donc tout va bien tout va bien
tout ce beau monde a le sourire les
premiers piège du mali ont été évités la
colère de gaston rails et abandonné par
ses équipiers
c'est une autre histoire maire de gens
et c'est la dernière fois que je roulais
bien élevé ça tu peux émettre dans le
journal c'est vrai il est le rubino
derrière je les billets achetés dans la
baignoire qui couve toujours la
politique d'essayer de gagner le titre
alors que idy n'est pas capable de
gagner et roule comme un mouton derrière
réseau d'enchaînements dit qu'il reste
des qui roule avec moi et qu'on essaie
au maximum si je crève qui me donne une
roue qui face à bayonne a dit oui et
aujourd'hui quand on est ensemble alors
dans la brousse les que j'étais crevé je
suis est ce que tu veux pas eddy médy
bien vite pour qu'on répare i'm sorry
tilly les continuer alors si c'est ça
biais vers une hécatombe dans le désert
remondis gabbro ragnotti et zaniroli se
sont perdues 10 heures de retard x en
profite pour prendre la deuxième place à
1h47 de meds de porsche en tête en moto
moins de dégâts le classement a peu
évolué mais les camions s'ils ont perdu
10 heures surtout de roye et capitaux
gwan est provisoirement en tête
la société antenne 2 consciente que
certaines images de ce reportage
comporte un aspect de publicité en
faveur du tabac interdit par la loi
affirme n'avoir été guidée que par le
seul souci de donner d'un événement
d'actualité une information directe et
spontanée l'exécution d'un arrêt de la
cour d'appel de paris du 10 janvier 1986
oui ces images que nous vous montrons
chaque soir elles sont tournées par
henri gal et jean-marie le quartier qui
font un travail très difficile et très
réussie vous l'avez vue sur les pistes
du paris dakar avant de passer à la
météo les pronostics de lionel ovadia
pour le derby qui se court demain à
vincennes des pronostics
en chiffres et en images tout de suite
une seconde à plus de 2 millions de
francs pour cette petit numéro
c'est le rapport du dernier derby un
chiffre qui fait rêver celui qui nous
est proposé demain semble un peu moins
difficile à déchiffrer que le précédent
certes la première épreuve n'est pas à
l'abri d'une grosse surprise mais il
faut bien reconnaître que les deuxième
troisième quatrième et cinquième course
laisse entrevoir les victoires des
groupes 13 22 31 et 36 il reste bien sûr
à faire mouche dans les premières 6e et
7e épreuve mais en limitant les risques
on peut tenter les groupes cette 42e et
54e ou les favoris semblent assez
solides pour me résumer voici mon choix
pour ce derby de vincennes du côté des
favoris le 7 le 13 le 22 le 31 le 36 le
42 le 54 et 56 pour les outsider le 2 le
12 le vin le 30 le 34 et le 46
voilà maintenant la météo échevelé et
enrouée de laurent doucier mais oui
encore du vent encore des nuages encore
de la pluie ça arrive ça arrive ça
arrive de l'atlantique on n'en voit pas
la fin
regardez la photo satellite vous allez
voir ça continue à arriver à ça c'était
pas photo voilà la photo satellite une
énorme masse de nuages sur l'atlantique
poussé par des vents qui était très très
fort aujourd'hui il ya eu tempête qui se
glisse un petit peu une énorme masse de
nuages qui va de nouveau demain affecté
l'ensemble de la france alors regardez
la carte du temps prévu c'est les foires
et les nuages euse on n'y peut rien
c'est comme ça avec un temps variable
mans mauvais sur toute la moitié nord
peut-être des chutes de neige en plaine
sur le nord-est du pays
quelques éclaircies surtout beaucoup
d'averses un temps très gris sur la
région poitou charentes sur l'auvergne
le limousin la région la franche comté
le nord des alpes
un temps très nuageux avec des pluies et
des chutes de neige les risques
d'avalanches demeurent très importants
enfin attend un petit peu plus clair
mais ça c'est toujours la même chose
depuis plusieurs jours sur les bords de
la méditerranée à noter que le mistral
et la tramontane continue
côté températures que c'est la baisse un
petit peu heureusement vous me direz
quand même de 6 à 8 degrés sur la moitié
nord
une grosse majorité de 7,7 degrés à
paris et 2,6 toujours mais jusqu'à 13
degrés en corse sur la moitié sud voyez
ça reste doux m6 est en baisse côté
agenda
ça change comme tous les jours demain
c'est mercredi 2 jeudi 15 janvier pardon
le soleil se lève à 8h41 se couche à
17h20 deux minutes de soleil en plus et
c'est la saint géniez leur bonne série
mais le rappel des principales
informations de ce journal d'abord un
hold up sanglant à paris dans le 16ème
arrondissement un policier a été tué et
un autre grièvement blessé
et puis plusieurs personnes ont été plus
légèrement touchée après la fusillade
enfin les déclarations de valéry giscard
d'estaing qui entrait de plain pied dans
la campagne électorale la cohabitation
ça peut marcher
de toute façon le premier ministre sera
indéboulonnable a dit valéry giscard
d'estaing dernier journal bernard
pradines aux environs de 23 heures 20
demain matin n'oubliez pas votre premier
rendez vous c'est télé matin à 6h45 pour
soir à demain matin
e